- Hello and welcome everyone to today's,
Brilliant Minds, Bold
Questions Virtual Talk.
Our series spotlights high impact research
from across the academy,
from computer science,
population and public
health, to economics.
And today, molecular microbiology.
If you are not familiar with us,
CIFAR is a global research organization
that convenes extraordinary minds
to address the most important questions
facing science and humanity.
My name is Kate Geddie.
I am senior director of research at CIFAR,
and it is my distinct
pleasure to introduce you
to our two speakers for today's talk on,
What actually killed the dinosaurs.
First. We have our Arturo Casadevall,
all who is a Bloomberg
distinguished Professor
of molecular microbiology and immunology
and infectious diseases at
the Johns Hopkins Bloomberg
School of Public Health
and Johns Hopkins School of Medicine.
His research focuses on
host defense mechanisms,
how fungi caused disease
and in the development
of antibody based therapies
for infectious diseases.
He is also the advisory committee
chair of CIFAR's program
on the fungal kingdom,
threats and opportunities.
Second, we have Rebecca Shapiro,
a CIFAR Azrieli global scholar
in the same fungal kingdom,
threats and opportunities program.
Rebecca is Assistant Professor in
the Department of Molecular
and Cellular Biology
at the University of Guelph
where she examines the
biology and pathogenesis
of certain fungal species.
Today's session will last
approximately 30 minutes.
I will start with a question
before inviting our speakers
to ask one another questions
for about 20 to 25 minutes.
After this, I will open it up to questions
from participants online.
So if you're an online audience
member and have a question,
you can use the Q and A
function to submit it.
We do ask that you not
use the chat function
to submit questions.
Lastly, this session is being recorded
and will be available on
the CIFAR website next week.
So to get us started,
most of us are brought up
to believe that a meteor hit
the earth, leading to the
extinction of the dinosaurs,
but as this talk title suggests,
it seems that it might
not be quite so simple.
What is missing from this widely held idea
and how do fungi fit in?
- So Kate, thank you for your question
and thank you for inviting me.
I think the general explanation
that a meteor did it,
is the right explanation.
I mean, but there are nuances to this.
The event is thought to have
been a collision from something
about 17 miles in length
that hit the Yucatan
65 million years ago.
And it would've caused a
tremendous calamity in the earth,
massive tsunamis going
through North America,
rapid warming of the atmosphere,
massive amount of dust,
and then fires on the earth.
So anything at the top of
the food chain would've been
in trouble, dinosaurs were
the top of the food chain,
but the, and probably
perhaps some survived.
But the question is what
happened in the aftermath
of the calamity,
what happened in the month
and the years after that?
And what hopefully we'll talk about is,
is a world dominated by the fungi
and anything that survives,
anything that made it then,
would've had to deal with
a massive fungal bloom
as the planet became a global compost.
- So I think maybe jumping
in on that, you know,
what then precisely were the
sort of conditions of the,
this post meteor world and
how did they specifically kind
of favor fungal growth?
- So there has been a lot of work
reconstructing the calamity.
You can imagine that the
immediate blast would would've led
to rapid heating of the atmosphere.
And then these shock waves
would have basically went
around the world.
And two things will happen then.
The tsunamis, the shock waves,
will have knocked down the trees,
but the what really hurts the
plant life is large numbers,
large, millions of tons of earth
are basically kicked into low orbit.
And these now will obscure the sun,
shutting down for photosynthesis.
Now, many of those rocks
are in unstable orbits
and will begin to come down
and they come down as flaming meteorites.
So you have fires,
you have the death of vegetation,
and you have rapid cooling,
the earth cools very rapidly after that.
So you have dark,
dead vegetation and cool.
And those are the ideal
conditions for a fungal bloom.
- So where does then the link
with dinosaur extinctions come in?
So given the sort of
conditions that are favored now
in this really terrible
sounding, you know,
apocalyptic world, how,
why are fungi then favoring
infection in dinosaurs
at this stage then?
- So what, the way I look at it
is that clearly things survive.
We are here.
So clearly our early on ancestors made it,
clearly, our reptilians made it.
We have reptiles today.
We got iguana.
Insects made it, dinosaurs didn't make it,
but you know,
dinosaurs were in all kinds
of shape from enormous
to smaller ones.
And one potential explanation for this is
that certainly mammals with their internal
combustion engines, they remain warm.
The others, certainly
the reptiles, didn't.
What happens when reptiles
are cold, they can't move,
they can't digest food.
So these conditions would've given
a huge advantage already
to anything that was warm.
And now you could add the fungal spores.
So in this cataclysmic
post apocalyptic war,
you would've had massive
amounts of fungal spores and it,
you can always overcome
an immune system with
insufficient inoculum.
So for the cold blooded animals,
they would've been at
a great disadvantage,
not only nutritionally,
not only moving around,
but now having to deal
with massive numbers
of fungal spores.
In the meantime, our small
ancestors would've done well,
they could move, they could eat mushrooms,
they could eat all kinds of things,
and they would establish
much larger populations.
So when the skies cleared and
the earth begins to recover,
now you have a lot more
mamas than you have reptiles,
large founder populations,
and then you have the ancient mammals.
- And what, do we have any real,
do we have like concrete evidence from
the fossil record for this?
How do we, you talked about, you know,
huge blooms of spores in this time.
Do we know that that happened?
- Yes, there is fungo.
There is in the fossil
record, what is known,
the KT boundary.
That is the Cretaceous tertiary boundary.
There is evidence for
massive fungal proliferation,
not only there, but if
you go back in time,
this happened 65 million years ago.
If you go back to the Permian extinction,
there, the fungal layer in
some parts of South Africa
is as much as one meter, think about that.
one meter of fungal spores.
So anything that survives ,
the fungi will always do
well when things go bad
for other organisms, okay.
They, and they do very
well because they tend
to degrade matter and they will
survive in this environment.
And they, when they survive,
they produce larger spores,
and large amounts of
spores means that you have
to make it through this fungal bloom.
So yes, there is fossil evidence
for massive fungal proliferation in
those two great calamities, the Permeant
and the KT boundary.
- And so it seems like,
temperature really then
is the big player here
that warm blooded mamas sort
of had the advantage here
to protect themselves
against fungal infection.
So how does that, how does
that sort of play out,
in the world today?
And if we're thinking about, I don't know,
a world of changing
climate and temperature,
if, how will this potentially
impact what we see
with fungi today
and susceptibility of
different kinds of animals?
- That's a great question, Rebecca.
The, I mean, the way I came into this was
because it always bothered me,
the question, why mammals,
I already had three meals today.
You know, if I was reptilian,
I can probably do with one meal a week.
I mean, how do we end up having,
selecting large animals that
have to eat all the time?
That doesn't make any sense to me,
unless there was a selection mechanism,
something had to favor being hot and then,
so this, so what I, the way
I think about it is that
this temperature creates
a thermal gradient
between us on the outside.
Now it turns out that we looked
at a susceptibility of fungi
to temperature, about 10 years ago,
and most fungal species
cannot tolerate 37 degrees.
They simply stop growing.
So just being 37 degrees is giving you
a tremendous protection
against the fungal kingdom,
which is by the way,
the major passages of plants,
a cold blooded animal,
insects, and many others.
So guess what's happening
in the world today?
The world is getting warmer.
So it, what is this going to do?
Well, one, you have a lot
of organisms out there
that maybe the temperature
max is 34, 35, 36 degrees,
but they are loaded with the capacity
to cause disease in other organisms,
but they can't break through
your temperature barrier,
but what would happen if they adapted?
Then as a result of a warmer climate,
then we can be post, we
can be facing new threats
from the, we don't even know yet
because they haven't
been a problem up to now.
- And so, and I guess, adding on to
the kind of temperature
question here, then where do,
where do other animals fit in?
I think if my basic biology is correct,
I think birds are even
warmer than us humans.
So, are they, are birds going
to take over the world next?
Is that going to be kind of
our trajectory from here?
- Well they, it's interesting you,
I'm glad you bring in the birds.
So the birds and the mammals are the two.
And by the way, the crocodiles,
I don't know what's going
on with the crocodiles,
but the birds,
the mammals, and the crocodiles are
the major groups that make it through the,
do well after the KT calamity,
the birds are already pretty high.
The birds are quite resistant
to fungal diseases except
for one kind of fungus type,
which are already thermally adapted.
And that's the Aspergillus,
the Aspergillus family is often what you
find in a compost.
You know, you drive by,
you see a compost, you
see smoke coming out.
Those are fungi.
They're carrying on metabolism.
These are, those fungi
are already quite adapted.
And for whatever reason,
the birds are susceptible
to aspergillus, but they
are pretty resistant
to everything else.
You can't, for example,
pigeons that are associated
with cryptococcosis,
but you can't give a pigeon
a cryptococcal infection
because their temperature is 42.
So they are able to do so.
So the birds, why are the birds hot?
Probably because flight
requires a tremendous investment
in energy and the hotter the energy,
the more efficient it is.
So it turns out that
in the case of birds,
in the case of the primitive mammals
that were around,
they were pre adapted perhaps
for different conditions.
- Very interesting, and so maybe
to kind of circle back
to Kate's original question,
then, how did this whole idea emerge?
How did you put,
how did this theory sort of
come together, given what,
you know, we currently know
about fungi, but of course,
without being able to actually have
a record of what would've happened during
the time of the dinosaurs?
- Well, I mean, I like
to read outside my field
and I pride myself that every day I try
to read something about
my, outside my field,
and the astro hypotheses came
to be in the early eighties
when it was, when an
iridium level was found.
And that's what give the clue
that it came from outer space,
between, in the KT the boundary.
But, I always been bothered
by the question, why mammals?
Now people say, well, you
know, you had a calamity
and it created a space
and the mammals moved in
because the dinosaurs are not there.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
You know, you still have reptiles,
you'll still have others.
Why do you end up selecting something
that needs so much food?
You needed to have something
at the end of the day,
that for which this temperature
provided an advantage,
otherwise we make no sense
and that separated the birds.
The birds already had that
advantage in the sense
that they need it.
They may have had it for flight,
but for the terrestrial
one of us, the creatures.
And so, that always bothered me.
It never made any sense to
me that people said, well,
a space got created and
the mammals took over now.
You need to have something.
And then what happened,
reading out, reading, trying
to read in other areas,
I came to that article showing in 2003,
over a fungal bloom
around the KT boundary,
that was published, I
believe it was in Science.
And the two things began to make,
began to fit in together, fungal bloom,
thermal protection, mammalian dominance.
So it's really a thought,
it's this idea comes from linking
in very different aspects,
facts into new thought.
- And is there anything that we can then
take from this and sort of apply?
If we're thinking about how
to protect either ourselves
as humans or other animals
against fungal infections,
can we exploit this idea of temperature
as being sort of protective?
Or is there somewhere
we can sort of take this
and learn from this?
- I think that, yes, I think
that there's a lot to do here,
but maybe first we can visit the bats.
So it turns out that the
bats in North America
were doing pretty well up to 2006.
In 2006, a fungus was
introduced from Europe
that is a cold loving fungus.
So it can only grow in cold temperatures
and began to kill the bats.
It began in New York and in New York state
and it spread through
a whole new continent
and the bats are susceptible in
the winter, not in the summer.
So the bats, the reason is,
in the temperate climates,
there is no food.
So the bats hibernate,
the fungus grows on them and
essentially wakes them up
in the middle of the winter
because they're sick and
they can't feed and they die.
If you take those bats from
the cave to the laboratory
and feed them, just giving them food,
drives up their metabolic rate,
and they can clear the fungal disease.
That's giving you a tremendous,
powerful anecdote of the
power of temperature.
Another example are the
frogs that are infected
with the Chytrid fungus.
If you bring them into a lab
and you put them at 37 degrees,
you can cure them of the Chytrid.
So, it is possible.
So there are a couple of
things you can think of,
you can think of that
for infectious diseases
that are acquired from the environment,
that we may be able to
explore temperature,
that perhaps we shouldn't
be giving everybody
Tylenol when they have
a severe fungal disease,
that the temperature,
increasing the temperature
could make the fungus
more susceptible to the
internal environment.
The other thing to think about
is that temperature pathways
may be targeted in drug development.
We know very little about how do you adapt
to higher temperatures.
This is an area that, you know,
almost, let me give you a thought example,
almost everything we know in immunology
is done at 37 degrees,
but immunology in your
skin happens at 31 degrees.
You would think that there has to be
a lot of more research
looking at a temperature
as a variable in all aspects
of micro and pathogenesis.
But yes, I think that,
that it is something that
we currently don't target.
So it is a target to me,
it's a target for exploration
of possible opportunity.
- Very cool, and,
so it sort of centering
this around reptiles
and the dinosaurs and the
sort of advantage of mammals,
but to today, we know that
certainly humans and other,
I think other mamas are
still to a extent susceptible
to fungal disease.
So is this just sort of
the exception to the rule
or where does sort of human vulnerability
to fungal infection then fit in?
- So I think that the
fungal diseases emerge
in the 20th century as a major,
we know tuberculosis from antiquity.
We know a lot of diseases
from a long time,
but fungal diseases really
begin to take off up to 1950.
What happens in 1950,
corticosteroids are developed.
Chemotherapy is developed.
Then in the 1980s,
you have the HIV epidemic.
What do all these things have in common?
They interfere with our immunity.
So there are two pillars
to our resistance.
One pillar is immunity,
advanced immunity, having
T-cells, B cells, innate immunity,
you name it.
And the other one is temperature.
So what we saw in the
20th century was that
if you mess around with
the pillar of immunity,
you get more fungal diseases.
What we are afraid of to
see in the 21st century
is that the fungi may
adapt and then defeat
or mess with our second pillar.
But I think it is a fact that
immunologically competent
mammals are remarkably
resistant to fungal disease.
They do occur, but they are very rare.
And what we are learning
now with genomic analysis
is that when you, when they occur,
they often tend to be some
sort of error, for example,
a mutation in detecting
pathway or signaling
or something like that,
that sets it apart.
So I would focus more on
the remarkable resistance,
and try to understand that,
rather than the susceptibility,
because I think we, the susceptibility,
that has many causes,
and you can certainly pave
the the way with drugs,
transplants, and things like that.
To me, that's a very
interesting scientific question.
- Definitely, yeah, I think
in our current pandemic era,
I think we're, we all, you know, I think
everyone is very attuned
to thinking about kind
of human vulnerabilities
and immunological kind of susceptibility.
So it's very interesting.
I mean, it's certainly
kind of an out there theory
and is different, I think from,
what we are used to thinking about
and not necessarily intuitive to kind
of center this important
event around these kind
of fungal species and the impact
that they've had.
So has there been sort of push back
to this theory?
Are there people who think otherwise?
- We have a good time.
Its one possibility that nobody cares.
- That's fair.
- Another possibility is that
people say, well, you know,
it may be.
And they, but I,
what I would say you is that
as a scientist, you know,
there are three big questions.
What, how, and why?
I mean, I'm on the other big questions.
So scientists are pretty good
at why, we describe stuff.
Now, people like to work on mechanism.
That's how you do it,
but we tend to stay away from the why.
The why gets into, often
gets people very, very,
worried, you get into metaphysics,
you get into theological
reasoning, whatever,
but I am interested in all three.
And to me the why questions,
it really often explain a
lot of the world as it is.
So to me, a lot of this came from,
I'm trying to understand the
why question, why mammals?
To me that's a really
interesting issue that if,
that needs an explanation
and whatever was out there
was certainly not sufficient for me.
And it's been a lot of fun,
look, this is something
you can talk at a cocktail party.
I mean.
- Absolutely.
- I can't talk about my other work
at a cocktail party without
having everybody leave.
- Yeah.
- Maybe I'll just jump to remind
any of the audience members
that if they have any questions,
they should feel free to drop
them into the Q and A section,
of the webinar.
And while I have the microphone,
I might take opportunity
to circle back to some of
the questions around temperature
and make a connection with climate change.
What do we,
do we think that climate
change may effect fungi.
And if so, how,
what about their ability
to cause infection?
- So we have one example
again, it needs explanation,
it falls into a white question.
I pose it to you,
Candida aureus was unknown
to medicine 'till 2007.
You can't find it in any
collection, you cannot.
In 2010 and 2011,
it emerges simultaneously
in three continents
and they're not, the clays are different.
So these are not that somebody took it
and flew from one country to
another, three continents.
Why would that be?
Why would you have this thing
emerge at the same time?
And then you may begin to look and say,
what is happening in common
on the three continents?
And we have proposed that this may
be the first example
of an organism adapting
to higher temperature and breaking through
the thermal barrier.
Now, whether it is right or not,
I don't know.
There, it was just recovered
in the Andaman Islands.
It turns out that the wild isolate,
it was less temperature
adapted than the ones
that they recovered from a beach
that could have been put there by humans.
So what I would argue is
that we need to focus,
why questions are fun,
why questions can drive
all kinds of research
and they can also open the areas
that we don't know that
could also be addressed.
- Hmm, good thing we have a program
called fungal kingdom,
threats and opportunities.
- Well, I'm glad you do.
- So I'll read another question
that's come in from the audience.
And they, they ask if you
have any comments on how long
the dinosaur extinction
event would have taken,
how abroad was the fungal bloom,
and how long would a fungal infection take
to kill a dinosaur?
- So I guess I begin by
saying, I don't know,
but, and then once you say, I don't know,
I think we can say things
like, well, there is evidence.
People have found evidence that they may,
still may have survived the initial blast.
It's really not clear
whether they all died
in around a few weeks
of that horrible day,
65 million years ago,
or whether in some parts
of earth, some survived,
then subsequently went extinct,
I think the fungal bloom
would've taken weeks to months
to years, you need to have vegetation die.
And we know what happens in the forest.
It takes a while for
things to begin to decay.
And, but it's probably, we
would be dealing with decades,
if not hundreds of years of
massive numbers of fungal spores
and whatever survived
had to deal with that.
- Well, so a related
question that has come in
is asking whether when
species became extinct
might be directly linked
to body temperature?
So the question is
related to the sauropods
that have 37 degrees
Celsius body temperature,
which became the dominant species
in the early Jurassic period.
- Yeah, so that,
but people said, the way
to preface that question is
how do, there is some evidence,
there is actually some evidence
dinosaurs were warm blooded.
How does this fit?
Well, notice what I'm saying. I'm saying
that the great killing of
this group of organisms
was the calamity.
There is, even though they,
the idea of high temperatures
in them may come from
the fact they are enormous
masses and they're anything.
And just having all that cytoplasm,
that double likely would
drive up the temperature.
But I don't think we have any
evidence that they regulated
the temperature like we do,
or that they could've been
able to maintain those
temperatures when, when in a situation
of dropping global
temperatures, lack of food.
So I think that it's not a
problem for this hypothesis
because the postulation
is those large ones,
probably were the top of the food chain
and that would've been in
deep trouble in the calamity,
whether they were right near it
or on the other side of the earth.
- We're almost out of a time.
So maybe I'll close
with one last question,
but it, the question is if fungi have,
haven't traditionally co-evolved
to be human pathogens,
will increased tolerance
to higher temperatures
by climate change
be enough to make them
serious human pathogens?
- So what, people often say, you know, or,
becoming a pathogen is a good thing.
What is the data for that?
In fact, I would argue that
most microbes pay a price
in getting the capacity for virulence,
what does it give you?
Well, it gives you a new place to grow,
and it may give you transportation.
If you're getting to an animal.
They can be moved around.
But when we actually wrote
an article about the cost
of virulence, so when people say, "Well,
why haven't the fungi adopted?"
Well, you know what,
this may not necessarily
be in their best interest,
or there may have be no
selection pressure for it.
But I think that if we get
more, it will be by accident,
you will basically end up
raising the temperature,
the thermal temperature
in which they can grow,
because they have to
live in a warmer world.
And some of them will be
loaded with the characteristics
that will allow it to cause disease.
There is no intelligence behind this.
There is just evolution and selection.
- Well, thank you both so much for sort
of a whirlwind tour and a fascinating talk
on what is a fascinating hypothesis.
So thank you so much to Arturo Casadevall,
and to Rebecca Shapiro for sharing
your insights with us today.
And thank you to all the
audience members for joining in.
We'll have a recording
of this talk available
on our website, CIFAR.CA,
likely sometime early next week.
So thank you all.
- Thank you for having me.
It's been a lot of fun,
science is a lot of fun.
- That's right thanks.
(Arturo mumbling)
- Wonderful, thank you.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)